[Music]
today's question comes from robert in
kentucky i used to be a business owner
and my minor children were on the
payroll for modeling on our website and
doing commercials
their pay was just enough to fully fund
their roth iras
now i have sold my business so they know
so they no longer receive w-2s can i
fund their iras by having them do chores
around the house if i keep track of the
chores and the amounts paid no no
won't survive an audit so um you have to
have an earned income to fund an ira and
you have to file a tax return on the
earned income
and um
no you can't uh
have them work for you now what you can
do and what i did with rachel daniel and
denise
was that any work that they did at the
office like you had done i mean we
didn't do any modeling but um we had you
selling books at the uh you were the
cute kid selling books at the book table
but uh you actually did work your little
tail off um and um
so we we paid you
well for that kept track of that and um
and then i added up anything that you
all made outside of our home babysitting
uh dog sitting
yard cutting whatever but integrity
snacks had to be something outside of
our home you cannot pay a kid for doing
chores and file taxes on it but you can
do that if they work doing something
outside the home because someone else
has paid them and is an income and then
you file that income
and pay income tax on
the income if it's taxable in that
situation if there's enough there and
whatever that amount totals up to
up to the maximum on the roth ira you
can put in so like i remember one year
one kid made like 123 dollars
and we added it all up and that's all we
could
uh
with integrity
before god
tell the irs that they had really made
we don't we didn't lie about it in other
words and so i filed tax return on that
kid
dollars and i opened a roth ira now i
paid the taxes this is a 14 year old or
something you know i paid the taxes
and i put the money into the roth ira
the 1200 bucks into the roth ira but it
enabled me to where you guys all came
out of college with a pretty good amount
it wasn't like 200 000 or something but
it was
it was north of 50 grand probably and
that they had all grown to and you've
done them a little bit of time from the
time you're about 10
up through 18 or whatever and we file
tax returns on you every year and so
that you have proof that there's an
earned income so that when you file it
now if you don't file the tax return
you're going to get in trouble and if
you can't justify
proof that there's
you can't you can't have someone
come to your office and do modeling and
pay them eight hundred thousand dollars
when you could have hired another model
for two thousand dollars
you can't do that okay you have to has
to be market value for the labor now it
can be the upper end of market value for
the labor but you know so uh when you
guys did work here at the office in the
summers we did we paid you well
so that we could fund that thing but we
didn't pay you like 5x of what we would
pay someone else because you can't that
won't survive an audit it's not it's
didn't have it's not a marketplace wage
and so that's how you can do that but
it's a good it's a good question and
it's what uh baby step seven that's
where you would do stuff like that you
would not do that if you don't have your
mortgage paid off yeah you pay your
mortgage off you would not do that while
you're putting more that you put more
than 15 away for retirement you would
not do that while you haven't funded the
kids college fund and instead you funded
the roth ira you would not do that so
this is all after
everything else is done house is paid
off at baby step six
now we're just loading up anything we
can load up and that sets the kid up and
wow and you know realistically they can
be millionaires well before they're 30
if they stay out of debt don't have
college debt because of you and you do
stuff like that because of you
and then they come into their first home
and you're able to help with that
because of you you do all of those kinds
of things you could set that if the kids
got their
head screwed on sure you know then then
they can come out the math comes out
really well in their favor well and it's
just and it's the intentionality and i
feel like that's
a little bit of that idea like when
people say like
the rich get richer kind of thing right
like it's a different mindset but when
you have the mindset of baby step seven
when you don't when you as a person you
have no payments your house is paid off
you're funding college it almost gives
you the bandwidth to think okay how can
i continue to change my family tree what
is what is that
how do you continue to pass on not just
the
the monetary side of it
but also the character side of holding
it yeah you teach them the hard work
ethic and uh saving in generosity versus
a home where nothing is ever talked
about you're just you know i mean and
this isn't a conversation there's no
teaching there's no guiding there's
nothing
then your child has to start from ground
zero as an adult
probably getting themselves out of debt
and trying to figure this out right so
it's just the whole changing your family
tree it's it's a it's a it's a big scope
a big scope
yeah it is it's more holistic than
simply the math totally yeah
that's what you're saying for sure yeah
and you're right it is the answer
because i didn't grow up in a rich
household i mean we weren't poor i
didn't go without food or anything but
we weren't rich i mean we knew those
rich people lived over there you know
and so uh when when i decided i was
going to become a student of rich people
uh the rich get richer is is how the
that's how people that are mad about it
always say ah their it's getting richer
targeting power yeah yeah because they
keep doing rich people stuff
which is intentionality it's not
screwing people they just think about it
when i you know the way i grew up you
wouldn't have thought about doing
something like fund the kids roth ira we
weren't even funding our own roth iras
let's talk about funding some 12 year
olds roth ira right that's that's an
intentional like you said that's
intentionality well and you have the
bandwidth mentally to say you're not
worried about you know putting food on
the table and paying the bill next month
when you're out of that mindset
something happens when you don't have
debt you have an emergency fund you
follow this plan
there is a
a shift i think that you just you have
the capacity in your mind to start
thinking okay what else can we do
creatively to
to help our family well it opens up both
investing and generosity yes because
you've got the bandwidth and the
bandwidth doesn't come from more money
the bandwidth comes from being on a
budget right
and when these folks say you know what
what got you out of debt i always i
always say the budget everybody says the
budget because what the budget does is
you're telling your money what to do
instead of wondering where it went and
no one tells money to do something
stupid on purpose but we've all done
something stupid with money because we
didn't bother to tell it what to do yes
and so when you're thinking about it
like that that's what rich people do yes
do you want to recommend utmost
do i recommend them yeah you can do them
it's just an account in the kid's name
but i know would you it doesn't grow
tax-free right so would you recommend
parents let's just say you have parents
listening on baby step 7
go that hey
kid work work work we're going to file
taxes on you we're going to do the roth
ira route
that's more i would do the roth and i
would do a 529 for college yes those are
before i did a nut yes that those are
yeah and better favor for the child long
term right well the ut my uniform
transfer to miners is simply any account
in the kid's name yeah if you open a
savings account at the bank it's an utma
yeah technically under the law it just
means because kids are if you're not 21
or not 18 in some states you can't do
contracts so you can't open a bank
account so your parents open it in your
name and they are named the custodian
and that is an atma but that happens
with a mutual fund or technically a 529
is it falls under that because i've
heard of some parents doing that instead
of call instead of like an esa or 529
yeah but they're not getting the tax
break yeah
and so no you're missing out on the free
tax growth tax-free growth is not an
utmo
so no i wouldn't do that i would do the
529s first
but everybody's always trying to game
the system so instead just bother to
care
and that game's the system that's what
rich people do rich people are not
consumed with money they're not greedy
it's just they are students of it
rather than students of victimhood now
some poor people are poor
not because of their
uh
bad habits some people are poor because
they're in a situation where they're
being oppressed by another people group
in some way
and so poor people are often taken
advantage of and it keeps them poor
and that's that's not good i mean we
never endorse that but but you know
every time i have done something stupid
with money it made me more poor
you lost money you know that goes with
it part of it is that okay part of it is
you're doing stupid stuff with money and
part of it is just the evil that is in
the world that you know payday lenders
taking advantage of people right that
kind of stuff and you don't see payday
lenders in the rich into town there's a
reason